hi I'm Roman meta director of power
computing technology at welcome research
I will talk about persistence and
initialization I will show the new 11.2
features for stowing information at
various locations and how to use it for
kernel initialization ok good afternoon
I'd like to present you some new things
you can do with your enterprise private
cloud
we brought parallelism to the private
cloud environment and so I'll show you
some technical issues there and discuss
the licensing options what you actually
need to use it inside your own
organization so we have a new thing
called HPC accelerator for private cloud
it hasn't been officially released yet
so this is kind of a preview we are
still figuring out some of the details
but technically it's ready and I can
give you a demo today so it supports
parallel computing in the same way that
it you do parallel computing on the
desktop so the idea is that it should be
the same experience and what this
requires is some extra software in the
cloud kernels to allow launching sub
kernels for parallel computing and of
course licensing options for those
parallel sub kernels and the idea is
that it looks the same I mean the as
with the desktop so how does parallel
computing look on the desktop so the way
you use it you launch some sub kernels
here I launched for kernels on my local
machine then I do some parallel
computation I have here I command that
takes the numbers from 1 to 500 and
selects though
well 2 to the N spy minus 1 is itself a
crime this now happens in parallel on
those 4 kernels and when you are done
you close those kernels and in the cloud
you have a similar experience except
that you don't use the mathematical
content but you use your web browser
about the screen we look exactly the
same you will see it in a couple of
minutes and technically what's happening
is inside your PC or workstation you
have a couple of open windows with
notebook documents that are connected to
the mathematical form tend the front end
is connected to the session kernel
that's the kernel that does your
computations if you type 2+2 in this
notebook that gets sent to the session
kernel and to reply for gets bit goes
back to the notebook and usually all the
notebooks are connected to a single
session kernel although you could have
more than one session kernels and
parallel tools allows you to launch sub
kernels connected to this session
kernels what I showed you where local
sub kernels which run on the same
machine where the session kernel runs
but if you have additional hardware you
can also launch sub kernels on any
available remote machines here called
nodes typically nodes in a cluster in a
high performance environment so you will
have to make a call to log in to those
machines launch the kernels and then
make a connection and all of this is
supported by the parallel tools which
allow you to set up the configuration of
which curls you want to use
in the cloud we support the same two
models local and remote sub kernels but
you have to make up your mind what you
want because in the cloud we have to
restrict what users can do because it's
a shared environment so you cannot just
do all kinds of funny stuff here is the
situation where you have local kernels
in the cloud so the cloudy thing here is
your private cloud there's a big web
server there that services all the
requests and you can access it from
anywhere in a web browser or on a mobile
device now in a cloud there are typical
several session kernels each user each
user notebook here has its own session
kernel and the idea now is that from
that session kernel you can now launch
sub kernels so this user will use three
sub kernels and this user here one of
those would in this case use six sub
kernels but all those sub kernels run on
the same machine where the cloud itself
runs and this cloud machine is typically
a virtual machine that's what you get if
you buy the private cloud you get a
virtual machine image then you have to
find some hardware in your organization
where you can run this now this is of
course limited because I mean that
machine is always also serving the cloud
so it's probably doesn't have a lot of
additional resources so you cannot do
hundreds of kernels in this way if you
want to do hundreds of kernels you have
to provide your own hardware for doing
so so the picture then is similar as
before the private cloud your notebooks
are connected to a session kernel and
the session kernel then makes
connections to any of the available
remote compute nodes
and in this way you can scale it to
hundreds of kernels now what are the
technical requirements if you want to do
they're what we call the localhost
parallelism where the sub kernels run on
the same machine where the power cloud
ones you need enough compute course now
these are virtual compute course because
it's a virtual machine so this only
works if they are our hardware course in
the background that actually support
these computations and you need these in
addition to those compute course that
support the private cloud itself now the
private cloud is highly configurable so
you can decide how many kernels you want
to provide for the cloud itself and how
many you want to provide for doing
parallel computation and that's we have
maybe you have seen it yesterday in
Stevens Steven Wolfram's presentation
where he showed how the private cloud is
configured when you get the power cloud
you open a Mathematica notebook that
contains all the parameters for setting
up the power cloud and there is a new
such parameter that it's called parallel
computing and it allows you to turn on
and off parallel computing and if you
want to do computing on the same node as
the private cloud itself you would set
the compute nodes to localhost and you
can here specify how many kernels are
allowed for parallel computing then you
generate a new configuration for your
parallel cloud and then it will support
parallel computing now for cluster
parallelism where the parallel kernels
run on different hardware you need to
provide few more things obviously you
need to provide the hardware a cluster
or rack full of machines that are
capable of running the ball from engine
wolfram engine is Mathematica
installation without the front-end
documentation things you do not need in
this environment you need a network
between the power cloud node and those
compute nodes it should be as fast as
possible because that network will be
the bottleneck for the pilot for the
parallel computation because all the
communication goes between the private
cloud and those compute nodes and you
need licenses for the compute nodes we
do have special licenses for parallel
computation that are part of the old
great Mathematica which is still
supported I mean great Mathematica is
doing parallel computation from your
desktop and here we instead of form your
desktop you do it from the private cloud
but the backend the compute nodes are
the same so we can use the same
licensing schemes as we use for great
Mathematica and to configure your
parallel cloud like this you would
actually list the compute nodes here in
the cloud configuration the number of
kernels per node and if there are more
than one network interfaces and you may
have to specify the local end point of
those computation but normally this is
not necessary
yes the parallel the configuration
language is based on JSON and so it's a
comma-separated thing of no no names yes
I mean it's it's not standard I mean you
you but that's why we provide the
example writing a notebook so you know
what what you have to do and this then
turns into a list of host names inside
your session kernel now you need to do
one more thing obviously you need to set
up these compute nodes so they that they
allow login from the private cloud and
so and this is not something we can
provide because we don't know what
environment you have and we want to
support as many environments as possible
therefore we simply state the
requirements and your local system
administrator will then have to set up
those compute nodes so you need compute
nodes that support running the boy from
engine and support logging into which in
practice means one of the standard Linux
distributions and the wolfram engine
installed then you need to set up a
login name that the cloud can use to
reach those compute nodes and you need
to work from engine installed preferably
on a local disk and not on a network
disk if you have 100 compute nodes and
all of them launched on 8 kernels that
means 800 process starts at the same
time and if that both from engine
installation is on a shared disk that
server will break down at this point so
it's quite easy just put one copy of the
wolfman genome to each compute node and
then they will not have any bottleneck
they launched and the last requirement
is a fast Network between these nodes
now the communication tool to launch the
kernels from the guava cloud to the
compute nodes goes with SSH
and in the car by the cloud there is a
username that under which the cloud runs
and so you need to set we allow this
user to make SSH connections into your
computes and this is very easy to do you
just create an SSH public/private key
pair the public key has to go into all
the compute nodes which then allows the
head node which has the private key to
log into those compute nodes we provide
I mean when you set up the power cloud
you can log into that power cloud
yourself as you as the system
administrator and just copy the key
pairs in place and the network must
allow for these SSH connections and the
backward TCP connections for the kernel
connections now if it's on the same
network that's not the problem if there
are firewalls and net whatõs in between
and you will have to do a little bit of
configuration there but we assume that
this all is inside a protected
environment so you don't need to put
additional problems between the personal
private cloud and the compute nodes so
the security is outside and then you can
freely connect between those nodes
I should give you a quick demonstration
at this point we have set up it refuses
to quit full-screen mode here
I don't know what
this button doesn't I'm stuck in
full-screen mode
so there's probably magic
I have a link let me see okay now so
this is my web browser and it's
connected to that internal test cluster
the test cluster consists of a head node
running a private cloud and to compute
nodes with four cores each and in that
private cloud I have another copy of
this presentation notebook and two what
you see here is not the mathematical
intent but it's the web browser inside
being driven by the private cloud so you
can of course do any kind of evaluations
but more importantly you can do parallel
computation so what i'm doing here is
now running in the private cloud so i'm
connected with the web browser to the
private cloud and the power cloud has a
session kernel reserved for me where
these evaluations happen and I have the
same idea I can do launch kernels and it
will now launch the pre-configured set
of kernels for me to use here is some
information so I have the node name so
there are two nodes and four processes
on each of those and that's the username
under which this is all running then I
can do now the same kind of parallel
computation as before I mean there's
really no point in giving a long demo
because the parallel computing is
exactly the same now on the private
cloud as on the desktop I mean that's
the whole point of the exercise that we
bring you the familiar parallel
computing experience into the cloud so
what is now of course more important
than a desktop is when you're finished
with your computation
you should close those kernels because
somebody else might want to do parallel
computing and if two people who launch
each eight kernels then there is there
are more kernels running than there are
actual cause and so you will not see the
speed-up that you expect so that's
really all there is to demo I mean there
is nothing new on purpose we try to make
it so this is the situation that I just
demoed we have have connected from my
browser to a session kernel and the
session kernel has launched for sub
kernels on two nodes and the set up was
done exactly like this we have an SSH
key in the private cloud and there's
another technical requirement the
kernels in the private cloud do not
allow arbitrary connections to the
outside they run in a sandbox and so we
have a version of that remote kernel
launcher that interfaces with the
sandbox so you can make connections to
that pre-configured set of remote nodes
it also means the cloud protects is
protected against users trying to make
connections somewhere else so the
configuration is outside the user
session kernel so you cannot bypass
those restrictions now of course the
question is as I said before if two
people at the same time try to run the
full set of kernels then you might not
have the experience you would like to
have so what happens is the following
the default configuration in the cloud
is to use the full set of kernels but
you can actually decide to use fewer
than those
kernels available now on the localhost
parallelism
when you say launch kernels when you do
not give an argument here it will do use
the default but you can say I want to
use only two so two more are available
for somebody else and in the case of
using external compute nodes it looks a
little bit more complicated but the idea
is the same you can specify a subset of
those nodes that are available and say I
want to launch two kernels only on each
of these two nodes and then I can just
create my own configuration or you could
even have your system administrator
provide certain configurations not just
a default configuration but some other
ones that you can then reference by name
and so you could have a small
configuration for doing testing and you
could have a full configuration which
gives you everything there is for doing
the actual productive one so you are not
restricted to you always using the full
set of kernels but you can actually
decide to use only a smaller subset of
those now of course that doesn't really
solve the problem yet because it's still
a question of using the resource shared
with us so that you get past each other
I mean that's also the reason why this
technology does not exist in the public
cloud in the public cloud we cannot
assume that we have only nice users that
are will obey any restrictions that our
company policy but we'll have people
from all over the place who will just
for fun try to 100 kernels each and so
this kind of parallel parallelism only
works in a cooperative environment and
so it is up to your organization to put
up guidelines
maybe okay in the morning I use on the
Colonel's in the afternoon somebody else
uses a hundred curls or I have smaller
configurations where I can do debugging
with two or four kernels and then when
I'm ready to do the full computation
then I will reserve the machine for me
for a certain time we do not provide a
software solution for doing this
reservation we don't have a full
reservation system at this time we
assume that this is a cooperative
environment where you can talk to each
other and decide who gets to use the
machine at what time of course this is
open to further development maybe at
some point we will be asked to provide a
reservation system a job scheduling
system you may be familiar with some of
this job scheduling system that exists
for supercomputers and so on and they
might do the same but at the moment we
on purpose did not do this we provide
the tools and your organization will
have to do the scheduling of the
resources it is also the case that if
you stop using a session kernel then the
session can have a timeout and when the
session kernel that has some sub kernels
attached times out the sub kernels will
quit automatically so you do not get
hundreds of rogue kernels lying around
it takes care of itself and it will only
keep them alive as long as the session
kernel is still being used so how do you
actually get to use this in the future
every private cloud will support the
configuration for parallelism so what I
showed you at the beginning you can open
the configuration notebook for your
private cloud you can enable parallelism
there is no extra charge
for this but of course to actually use
it you need licenses for these kernels
and in the case of cluster parallelism
you need to configure that additional
hardware and SSH setup and of course
private clouds are typically sold with
the service support contract so this
support for setting up the SSH and the
compute nodes might be part of that
service contract for the private cloud
so if you are interested if you are
account by the cloud customer and would
like to use that or if you are
interested in the private cloud itself
just talk to us and we can tell you what
the possibilities are there is another
way we could provide this technology
that is a question to you whether you
are interested in this it would be
possible to have to set up
pre-configured images for example for
Amazon ec2 that include the private
cloud plus a set of compute nodes and
then you could obtain that image I think
there is just an hourly charge for using
it for a certain time and it would be
pre-configured so you could log into the
private cloud on the Amazon instance and
use say 200 compute kernels within that
instance that would be another way of
providing that technology would have the
advantage you don't have to buy your own
hardware you just rent the Amazon system
part of it for a certain amount of time
I mean that's particularly interesting
if you're not don't use that in
continuous mode but have maybe a need to
do something for one or two weeks and
then the computation stops and then you
you can just stop using it and you will
not be built for it for additional time
okay thank you
[Applause]